hi everyone this is Professor M designs
and today I want to tell you about one
of the most iconic problems in quantum
mechanics the one dimensional infinite
square well potential this is another
one of our videos on grigoris quantum
mechanics what does the infinite square
well potential describe it literally
describes a particle in a box and now
you may be wondering why do we care
about this relatively boring problem in
fact this is one of the most famous and
important problems in quantum theory and
there are two main reasons for that the
first one is that it is one of the few
problems that can be solved exactly in
quantum mechanics but still it displays
the most important features of this
theory the second one is that many more
complicated problems like electrons in
atoms are essentially electrons trapped
in a potential well and therefore what
we learn with the infinite square well
potential can be translated to all these
other problems so in this video we will
solve the mathematics of the infinite
square well potential and then we will
understand what it means from a physical
point of view I have also decided to try
something new in this video I have
written a jupiter notebook that
implements some Python code to allow you
to play with the solutions of the
infinite square well potential so check
the link to my github in the description
because it is something new if you like
it and want to see more code in the
future please let me know in the
comments with this let's get started the
very first thing we always do when we
encounter a new quantum problem is to
look at the energy spectrum of our
system in the position representation
that means that we have to solve the
equation shown here which is called the
time independent showing your equation
as well as the eigenvalue equation for
the hamiltonian in this equation e is
the energy of our system and at the
eigenvalue and sy of X is the eigenstate
of our system and in the position
representation we have here that's
called the wave function as a reminder
the first term in the equation
represents the kinetic energy of our
system and the second term in the
equation represents the potential energy
of our system in this equation the
kinetic energy term always has the same
shape
what allows us to tell one system from
another system is the potential energy
term so whenever we talk about a new
quantum system the first thing we have
to do is we have to define what the
potential energy is in this system in
this video I want to discuss the
infinite square well potential this is a
potential V of X
that has a wall here and another wall
here and the dashed lines represent the
fact that these walls are impenetrable
we're going to set the positions of the
walls at minus a over two and a over two
and mathematically the potential is as
follows v of x equals zero within the
walls so for absolute value of x small
and a over two and the potential is
infinite outside of the walls once we
have the potential that defined our
system we can replace it in the equation
above to find the eigen values and the
eigen states even before we start with
the mathematics we can in fact say a few
things about what the eigenstates should
look like outside the walls of the box
the potential is infinite which implies
that the wave function must vanish this
result makes intuitive sense but if you
want more rigorous proof check the video
in the description the second statement
that we can make is that the wave
function must be continuous you can also
understand it intuitively by remembering
that the absolute value squared of the
wave function is interpreted as the
probability density of finding the
particle at a given position and the
probability density must be continuous
however again if you want more rigorous
mathematical proof check the video
linked in the description so what does
it mean that the wave function must be
continuous in our case that means that
at x equals plus minus a over 2 then the
wave function must also be zero because
outside of the walls the wave function
is zero all we have left to determine
then is what does the wave function look
like within the walls in this case we
cannot make any simple statements and we
have to solve the mathematical problem
within the walls the potential is zero
so we plug this value in the equation
above we end up with the equation shown
here which is the mathematical equation
that we have to solve what we're going
to do next is we're going to forget
about the physics for a moment and we're
going to focus on the mathematics of the
equation that we have to solve this
equation is a second-order linear
differential equation and as all such
equations the trial solution is always e
to the ikx we can start by first
calculating the second derivative of e
to the ikx which after some
rearrangement gives us minus K squared e
to the ikx plugging this result into the
equation above we obtain this and then
we can cancel the e to the ikx terms on
both sides rearranging we find that K
squared is equal to 2m
e over H bar squared and taking the
square root we find two solutions for K
did we expect this result from a
mathematical point of view we did a
second order linear differential
equation has two independent solutions
and what this is telling us is that the
two solutions are given by e to the ikx
for these two choices of K moving
forward we're going to call the positive
solution simply K and the negative
solution minus K to build the general
solution to our problem all we have to
do is have to make a linear combination
of the two independent solutions so Phi
of X is equal to a e to the ikx plus b e
to the minus ikx where a and B are the
expansion constants which in general are
complex numbers before we move on let's
look at the expression here again and we
can rearrange it to find that E is equal
to H bar squared K squared over 2m this
is the eigen value of our problem
written down in terms of K so in order
to fully determine it we need to figure
out what K is the next step whenever we
solve the differential equation is to go
from the general solution to the
specific solution to our problem and in
order to obtain the specific solution
what we need to do me to apply the
boundary conditions of our problem
luckily we already determines the
boundary conditions at the very
beginning we decided that because the
wave function is continuous then the
value of the wave function at a over two
must be equal to zero replacing X by a
over two in the expression above for the
wave function we obtain this is equal to
zero we can then multiply both sides of
the equation by e to the minus I K al 2
and if we do that we obtain this and
then rearranging we obtain that a is
equal to minus B e to the minus I K a
the second boundary condition we have is
that the wave function must also vanish
at minus a over two and again replacing
the X by minus a over 2 in the equation
above we obtain this we then multiply
the whole expression by e to the IKr 2
to obtain this and then rearranging we
obtain a equals minus B e to the i ka we
now have two expressions for a which
means that the right hand side of these
two expressions must be equal and
therefore e to the minus i ka is equal
to e to the i ka multiplying the whole
thing by e to the i ka we obtain that
one must be equal to e to the 2i ka
and then we remember that one is equal
to e to the I 2 pi n 4 n being an
integer comparing these two expressions
for 1 we must have that 2 ka is equal to
2 pi N and rearranging this is telling
us that K is equal to PI and over a what
does this mean this means that K cannot
just take any value it can only be an
integer multiple of pi over a to make
this explicit we're going to write this
as K n to signify that this is the
specific value of K for a given end an
actual question to ask at this point is
why would K only be able to take this
set of discrete values the answer to
this is that the solution to our problem
is an oscillation e to the ikx and only
oscillations with the number of
oscillations that exactly fits within
the well is a valid solution to our
problem
this has an immediate very important
consequence for the energy because the
energy depends on K and if K can only
take these critters then the energy also
can only take these create values so you
can write e n is equal to this and then
we can replace the value of K and we
have just determined to obtain h-bar
squared PI squared M squared divided by
2 ma squared for integers n ok let's
take a step back and think about this
result what we have here is that the
energies of our system can only take a
set of discrete values labeled by the
integer n the fact that the energy can
only take a set of discrete or quantized
values is something that doesn't usually
happen in classical physics and this is
precisely what gives the name to quantum
theory now that we have determined the
allowed energy values of our system all
we have left to do is to determine the
wave functions associated with these
energy values to do that we remember
that the boundary conditions led to the
equation a equals minus B e to the ikj
we now know that the only allowed values
of K are the K n shown up here so
replacing that in this equation we
obtain minus B e to the I PI n e to the
I PI n is minus 1 to the N and therefore
the whole thing is minus 1 to the n plus
1 B which means that
is equal to B for odd n and is equal to
minus B for even n putting this together
we find that the wave function psi of X
is equal to a e to the ikx plus a e to
the minus ikx which is equal to 2 a cos
KX and then replacing the value of K
again we obtain 2 a cos PI NX over a and
this result here is valid for odd n we
can repeat the same exercise for even N
and in this case we need to remember
that B is equal to minus a ok so now we
have a nice expression for Phi of X and
all we have left to determine is the
constant a and we're going to start by
looking at the odd n solution to
determine a we require that the wave
function is normalized that means that
one is equal to the integral over all
space of the absolute value squared of
the wave function which represents the
fact that the total probability of
finding the wave function somewhere in
space is equal to one we plug in the
value of the wave function and we
remember that the wave function vanishes
outside the box so the integration
limits now go from minus a over 2 to a
over 2 the integral for the cosine
squared is a standard integral so very
quickly we replace the cosine squared
with this using a trigonometric relation
and then we integrate each of these two
terms to obtain this here the second
term vanishes at the boundaries that we
have and therefore we obtain to absolute
value of a squared a rearranging we
obtain that the absolute value of a
squared is equal to 1 over 2 a to
determine a from the absolute value
squared of a we have a phase choice to
make and we're going to make that phase
choice such that the wave function is
real so we're going to set a equals 1
over square root of 2 a replacing a in
the expression above we obtain Phi of X
is equal to square root of 2 over a
cosine of PI and x over a for all end
we can now repeat the exact same
exercise for even n we again have the
normalization condition and going
through the corresponding integral we
obtain the same expression that the
absolute value of a squared is equal to
1 over 2a in this case we're going to
choose a as equal to minus I over 2a and
with this phase choice we compare it to
the expression above and we see that the
two eyes will cancel and that we're
going to obtain a real expression again
putting everything together we now find
that the wave function Phi of X is equal
to a cosine for odd n and to assign for
even end many people when solving the
infinite square well potential make a
different choice of the origin to the
one that we have made they choose the
well to be between 0 and a rather than
to be between minus a over 2 and a over
2 choosing a different coordinate origin
of course doesn't change the physics but
it does change the maths so beware if
you compare this solution to a solution
with a different origin then the
mathematical expressions will be
slightly different but you should be
able to convince yourself that the
physics is exactly the same the reason
why I prefer the solution is because it
reflects the symmetry of the problem if
the origin is in the middle of the well
then the potential is symmetric with
respect to a reflection about the center
of the well what this means is that
parity is a symmetry of our problem and
therefore the Hamiltonian commutes with
the operator associated with parity pi
if you check my video on part in the
description then you'll see that this
means that the eigen state of the
Hamiltonian must have a definite parity
in our solution this becomes transparent
for all n the wave function is
proportional to the cosine and the
cosine is an even function so the wave
function has even parity and for even n
the wave function is proportional to the
sine the sine is an odd function so the
wave function has odd parity what's the
next step now that we know what the
energies and the wave functions of the
infinite square well potential are the
next thing we need to ask is what do
they mean if we look at the energy we
see that this whole term here is
essentially a constant and we're going
to call that constant epsilon and
therefore we can rewrite the energy as
epsilon N squared starting with the
lowest energy we're going to draw it
here it is Epsilon and it corresponds to
N equals 1
the next allowed energy value is here it
is for epsilon and it corresponds to N
equals two and we can also write down
the higher energy levels as we said
earlier the energy in the infinite
square well potential is quantized what
that means is that we cannot change the
energy of our system in a smooth way we
can only jump from one energy level to
another and in fact these jumps in the
infinite square well potential become
bigger and bigger because they're
proportional to N squared the next thing
we want to ask is what does the wave
function look like if we start with N
equals 1 then n is odd and therefore we
have a cosine like wave function we can
draw this wave function here and as we
argued earlier it is even on the parity
so that means that if we reflect one hub
of the well into the other half we
recover the same thing we know that the
wave function contains all the physical
information about our quantum system but
if we want to interpret what it means we
need to calculate the absolute value
squared of the wave function which tells
us the probability density of finding a
particle at a given position so let's
draw the corresponding probability
density for the ground state of our
system and what it's telling us is that
here near the center of the well we have
a high probability of finding the
particle because there is a peak in the
probability density and at the edges of
the well we have a very low probability
of finding the particle if we next look
at the N equals 2 solution then we see
that n is even now so we have the sign
solution we can again draw the wave
function in this case it is odd on the
parity so it will reflect 1/2 of the
well into the other half we then have to
multiply by minus 1 in order to recover
the wave function we can also look at
the probability density in this case
there are two peaks of high probability
on either side of the well and the
probability vanishes at the center of
the well where the wave function is zero
we can of course repeat this exercise
for any value of n that we want and it
is quite instructive to do it to let you
play with this I have decided to try
something new in this video I have
written a Jupiter notebook implementing
some Python code to describe the wave
function so check it out in the
description where there is a link to my
github if you think this is a good
and you would like to be able to play
more with code in future videos please
let me know in the comments what I have
here are two examples of the output of
the code so the first one here
corresponds to the N equals 10 energy
level this is an even n so it is sine
wave function and you can see that
indeed it goes to 0 at the origin the
one in orange corresponds to N equals
100 in this case there are many pigs
they are very close together so we can
draw a horizontal line here which tells
us that the absolute value squared of
the wave function is roughly constant to
some extent the result for very large n
can be understood by making a comparison
with what happens in classical physics
to do that we can see the classical
particle moving to the left inside the
box with a fixed kinetic energy 1/2 MV
squared the classical particle will move
towards the left at constant speed then
it will hit the wall reverse direction
and move towards the right at the same
speed and it will hit the other wall and
go back so we'll have this back and
forth motion inside the box in classical
physics if we know the position and the
velocity of a particle at a given time
the Newton's laws tell us where it will
be at any time in the future but for the
sake of argument let's imagine that all
we know is that the particle is moving
back and forth at constant speed but we
actually don't know what it started in
this case we can define a probability
density P of X which is telling us where
the particle could be because the
particle is moving at constant speed
then that means it is equally likely to
be found anywhere inside the box that
means that the probability is constant
and it is equal to 1 over a if we want
to normalize it with respect to the size
of the box if we compare this constant
probability with the constant
probability that we obtain for very
large energy levels in the quantum case
we then see that there is some sort of
analogy between the two and that's why
some people call the quantum case for
very large n the classical limit I
wouldn't want you to take this analogy
too seriously because in fact the
quantum and the classical cases are
fundamentally different when we know all
the information there is to know about
the classical case we have no
probabilities we know precisely where
the particle will be at any point in the
future the quantum case is fundamentally
different even when we know everything
there is
know about the quantum system that is we
know the wave function we still have a
probabilistic interpretation and we
cannot say for sure where a particle is
this becomes very obvious when we make a
measurement of the position of a quantum
particle and if you want to learn more
about that and to see how weird quantum
mechanics can become then check out the
video in the description so what have we
learned with the infinite square well
potential this iconic potential has
taught us about some peculiarities of
quantum theory most importantly the
quantization of energy levels there are
many other weird consequences of quantum
theory in the description I have
included links to a few videos where I
talk about for example how exciting
things can get when you measure what a
particle is or you can learn about
something as weird as quantum tunneling
if you liked the video and would like
some suggestions for future videos
please subscribe